do you think because I like I said
they're they're obviously has been a
like there was like a little motion
going in Dallas but there's a lot of
division that was obviously publicized
in Dallas obviously God Rest mode three
slowly passed away
um but they're always felt like any time
there was some [__] popping in Dallas
you would just I would just see like
people beefing with each other there's a
lot of negativity coming out um I feel
like that's not the same energy that's
happening right now
in terms of like just on from a Fan's
perspective the way I like it take you
and I'm like oh this dude's just raw
like yeah and that's what I'm saying is
that's why I was like Texas I feel like
is is trying to unite because since I've
been rapping like yeah you got you you
guys are people saying whatever but as
far as like you're gonna have your
haters yeah you're gonna have those but
as far as the like as far as the rappers
who everybody is for it you know what
I'm saying because they see somebody who
got their head down who just
trying to take care of his people yeah
so it kind of make them like
okay well if he's doing it he ain't
doing nothing but keeping his head down
doing everybody they like the music but
all the other stuff you ain't got to do
that for what what is that doing yeah
other than taking people's lives and you
know what I'm saying
so I don't know I just feel like you're
showing people that
you can you ain't got to do all that too
how big of an impact just from like a
kid coming up in Texas doing hip-hop was
someone like mo3 on you like because he
obviously I feel like was unfortunately
more appreciated after his passing no
for sure uh I mean if we're being honest
uh he had like he had like songs in the
city that just was obviously viral so
everybody knew him but I didn't really
listen to Three until after he Bears
when he passed I listen to his whole
album to this day wow so but I'm not
gonna say that
I just was oh I was I was a three fan
yeah no I wasn't until after when he
passed yeah and that's when I just
really started making music anyways
you're like damn like this dude really
was doing a lot of work a lot of the
melodic [__] at a high level he was
definitely something different and if it
wasn't before me it was gonna be him for
sure for sure 100 man I agree uh you're
obviously a Cowboys fan right no no okay
this is interesting who's your team
I want to say I was the Texans fan whoa
Texas
Jesus Christ you're getting Robin
tongues with DeSean Watson or what
what's going on and that's that's the
whole reason when I was today being
clammy first
[__] beast
you meant to say Bust but he was a beast
in college he was and then and then
obviously JJ Watt everyone thought you
had JJ Watt Clowney it's over but it
wasn't over we had uh clown I mean we
had the badger we had the defense was
stacked at one point in time yeah honey
badger was on the team oh so you're a
[__] you're from Dallas and you're a
Texans fan
what is going on there I don't think I
like football no more though I don't
think I ever how does that happen it was
the players like I was a I used to be a
Cowboys fan like I used to watch my dad
throw the controller at the TV a lot of
that I left the game did you decide I
don't want to live this stressful life I
did I watched my dad if I damned her
father his knees one game and I said oh
no yeah I can never be like that and so
I ended up falling in love with JJ Watts
Davey and clowning people like that man
it just kind of Drew me to restart off
with JJ though and that kind of Drew me
to the team and then
I just was a Texas Fan after that did
your dad look at you like yeah how could
you asked me I was gonna say I can
imagine
well I'm a Suns fan and one of my
younger Sons is pretty much growing up
in La so he's a Laker fan and I hate him
for it
like [__] if he was here he'd probably
say he ain't a damn Texas but then but
when the suns are in the finals he wants
to put on the [__] son's Jersey
that's crazy it's a little nine-year-old
ass yeah I'm pretty sure if the Texans
ever go to the Super Bowl he don't want
to be there
but as and if the Dallas Cowboys ever go
to the Super Bowl
hey don't do that don't do that I almost
said without laughing but come on guys
don't do that Mike McCarthy's your coach
anyway oh man I'm sure you'll support uh
yeah I got two man I got two not two you
guys got the crazy I went to
WrestleMania
at your stadium in Plano it's not Plano
is I stayed in Plano Madison uh the
stadium is in Arlington no I stayed in
Plano by the way shout out to Plano some
chicks over there too yeah there's a uh
what's the name of that restaurant where
they dress like a lumberjack prostitutes
uh uh Boomer Jacks no no no no no it's
like Hooters but like like [__]
checkered you got boomerjacks you got
Twin Peaks Twin Peaks
do a twin peaks in Plano and at a time
uh the Twin Peaks what's the one that
we'd be going to before we go to the
club
Bombshells bombshell go to bombs yeah
okay yeah yeah nice shout out to Plano
no but I went to the [__] stadium for
Wrestlemania that [__] was crazy so a
lot of people don't even know that's why
I damn near kind of got to be a cowboy
friend again because I just like the
technique just did a Remix They want me
to do a remix for Texas for for the
stadium next year just for the stadium
for the Cowboys what is that I mean for
the Cowboys for the stadium oh you're a
Cowboys fan
which one of those overpaid bumps
jerseys are you gonna wear with the
video
can I just get my name
hey you know what though Trayvon
I said overpaid
I'm really only speaking about well Zeke
Elliott ain't even on the team anymore
Dak Prescott like come on like you know
you know who's a beast wear the digs
Jersey Diggs
Tavon Diggs is a [__] yeah yeah yeah
yeah not a fan of him huh
do you guys have some interactions or
something
I mean I had an interactions with nobody
oh out of all of the Cowboys players
since you've been able old enough to go
to clubs who's the most outside
okay you want to be honest
who's outside so I like I go to clubs
but I'll go to like I still go to hole
in the walls like I love that's my [__]
I go to who showed me love from the jump
yeah and so for the first time ever I
went to like a
I go in there
and every Cowboys players and
decking there with his shirt on button
he [__] up it was just everybody was
in there everybody was in there so I
can't even just say one of them because
they was you should have brought your
dad with you so he could have went over
to DAC and said get the [__] home and
study so we can win a [__] playoff
game you soft ass [__] what are
we doing I look at him I said that's why
I'm not winning
I'm a Suns fan and I have good friends
on the sons
and a couple of them just they're at my
club a lot right so they're big
customers for our club you know 11 11 in
Scottsdale and uh
during the season you know I gotta be
like hey do I say something you got to
leave at eight hey man are you sure you
wanna
buy 10 bottles tonight there's a game
tomorrow
yeah yeah
and they pay it too every time because
they yeah I've never been to a club
where you you literally get ones just to
throw them just it's like a men hanging
party just to stupid see who makes
saying I I endorse I'm not gonna lie
it's a bunch of Cowboy players and I
gotta I gotta try to do something but I
ended up gaining some friends Jalen it
was named Jalen rigger oh yeah our
weaker yeah
yeah he's the white out yeah he was on a
eagle he was on the Eagles yeah he
played for the Minnesota man yeah
Minnesota yeah yeah he was there a lot
of people there what about have you ever
hung with DeSean Watson
I probably won't probably I feel like
he'd be a good time
just go hit an Asian massage parlor with
them
at the club and he said hey man I got
this uh have you ever been to a rub and
tug
it's like a massage parlor right where
you go to and there's like a little old
Asian lady in show like rub you down uh
I want to one time and then she'll flip
you over and then she'll jerk you off I
want to but I don't want to know that
that's what it is you kind of gotta know
that's what it is though otherwise it's
awkward no it's not gonna be awkward
I feel like it's not going to be ugly if
you go to one and you don't know it's
like kind of just like a oh it says like
what is this what is this why are you
reaching around and then you just go you
just go with the flow I don't think it's
a just yeah I feel like you knowing that
you're going now now you got to sneak in
and no I just I'm gonna go get a massage